[Music]
our very own cooking confidence coach
Nanny Bubby is back in studio thanks to
time in automotive the sponsors of this
segment today we are learning how to
make roasted Chestnut soup yeah so
excited but not before you get your own
spread love like butter apron from swag
how do you like that yes I will update
last time I got confirmation affirmation
card confirmation cards let me move my
mic so much yell at me the weather
outside is frightful and so what better
to be eating today rather than soup and
this is roasted Chestnut soup so let me
just tell you unless I am snowed in and
Brian Head unless there is absolutely
nothing else to do I am not roasting my
own chestnuts to make soup and that's
why you we get these fabulous you know
Melissa's Produce gives us all the
produce for our programs and this is is
how they come already roasted already
steamed already peeled you open that up
and put them in and why don't you taste
one I kept those out just for you to
taste it
okay so this is the first for me
whatever yes it is so let me just tell
you how we started this we started with
onions actually really good yes aren't
they they taste like brandy a little bit
um so we started with the onions and we
steamed and sweated the onions then we
um then we also put in carrots and
celery and now they've caramelized now
you can see the brown bits at the bottom
of there but that is not burned yes
that's caramelization and we are putting
in four ounces of Sherry into this right
it'll steam off the alcohol do you smell
bad
I do isn't that fabulous oh my gosh okay
and now what we're gonna do is just turn
this up a little bit because we want all
of this to get absorbed okay so while
this is absorbing and then we're going
to put everything else in but why don't
you put it pick a cooking affirmation
card because I will tell you what I am
anxious about with this recipe you're
you're anxious I'm anxious I'm anxious
because
this timing for the caramelization
absorbing of the Sherry just so what'd
you get what'd you say I feel like I got
this one last time I make time to cook
creatively today and every day so you
want to know what I picked that too is
that orange juice oh my God
yes okay it is it is Capricorn season
okay we turn this down and now what
we're going to do is we're going to add
six cups of broth calls for chicken
broth but my daughter's a vegetarian and
I'm taking this soup over to them okay
after this show then we're gonna also
add leeks and you want to show everybody
what leeks actually look like because
some people don't no maybe even you
don't but those are leaks there you go
okay putting those in you can put there
you go you can put that over there these
are the chestnuts God bless you Kendall
using the chestnuts and we chop them up
and those come right out of this bag
they're just ready to rock and roll so
okay mushrooms that's interesting they
do they do actually you're right and
also we're gonna put in two bay leaves
so one two three four and then we're
gonna let this simmer for about 25
minutes it's funny you put two bay
leaves in that giant pot That's How
Strong yeah they are so just put those
over there because we're going to come
back to over here okay and so now while
this is simmering let's step over here
let's take a look at this so we're going
to take these two bay leaves out okay
because they have it's not edible no
they're not and we are going to the one
thing that we're going to do is we're
going to take this soup and we're going
to use an immersion blender and Watch
What Happens here this is so fun yeah I
know it's so fun but it turns it very
creamy so so this is very brothy looking
correct but you're going to take this
and you go round and round it's gonna
step away yeah a step away no wonder you
gave me a favor today why are you wear
an apron and it's turned into an amazing
cream soup
so Mike you just turned that broth into
cream soup it it does and it just creams
because of the blender wow so you can
also pour this right into a you know a
home blender on the counter a counter
blender that's amazing but do you see
how creamy that gets where can you get
one of those
anywhere yeah Amazon Bed Bath and Beyond
Williams Sonoma okay so we have 30
seconds and I want to taste this all
right so here we go okay wow there we go
cool tool okay so into here so it's not
quite as Blended as I wanted it to be
bye-bye hey yes the flavors are
incredible so we're gonna take this it's
good we're going to put a little bit of
parsley as a garnish a little bit of
chestnuts on top and start your spoon
okay
mmm that is delicious it is delicious oh
that's perfect for a rainy day and every
day okay thank you check out Nanny
Bubby's kitchen and Garden on social
media and online at nannybubby.com
and we also want to thank Chapman
Automotive for sponsoring this segment
so good we'll be right back